[Musik]
etwas monströses hat er ja aber es hat
schon ein monster
im internet kursieren viele variationen
des grauens donald trump in grusel
klassiker shining als trockenste mutter
donata zillien das unheimliche wesen aus
einer fremden welt ist er also doch ein
muster der king kong der weltpolitik
das monströse an donald trump ist keine
erfindung empfindsamer linksliberaler
schreibt der kulturwissenschaftler und
sie nervt georg seeßlen in seinem buch
songs populismus als politik die rolle
des monster ist kein seiner politischen
inszenierung in der er auftritt wie ein
popstar
so funktionieren heute topstars er sehe
das in so eine ambivalenz funktionär von
einer ganz gewisse authentizität
einerseits haben und andererseits ja
fast rubbellos sich bedienen am fundus
der kultur am bundes der der ästhetik
empfindet der bewerbung auch etwas und
ich glaube donald trump ist einer der
ersten politiker die diese strategie des
popstars übernommen haben
georg seeßlen analysiert donalds amt als
produkt einer kulturindustrie die
unterschiedliche bilder und prototypen
entwirft die beamten nun über seine
politiker identität steckt
eine dieser maske zeigt das monster
trump dass sie an lauern des ungeheuer
seine rivalin hillary clinton um
schleicht
doch es ist nur eine maske von 4
wenn wir jetzt mit den mitteln der
popkritik einen donald trump der
konstruieren würden dank hin also ganz
unterschiedliche figuren heraus figuren
die wir aus populären filmen oder
romanen kennen
der selfmademan der sich als schule da
die schöne frauen hält der tycoon der
dich lieb citizen kane an immense sind
ihre mannschaft oder der archive
aufsteiger der das politische
establishment ins chaos
all diese medialen vorbilder dienen
einem fleck traum verdrängt so den
politischen diskurs der vernunft durch
emotionen bilder und effekte wie in den
weg zur macht eben trump ist kein
politiker sondern mehr die symbiose von
zwei figuren ein tycoon und volksheld
zugleich die figuren sind sind durch
durch etwas gekennzeichnet was man so
nennen könnte die digitale
selbstermächtigung das heißt es sind
menschen die die keine andere
legitimation haben als sich selbst und
in beiden mythen steckt auf die große
kränkung der händler erstmals man muss
zuerst unglaublich gekränkt worden sein
um so zu werden entweder tycoon oder
oder volksheld man könnte sich amüsieren
über die medialen vorbilder die rollen
in die dirnen traum schlüpft aber aus
dem spiel aus der provokation aus der
opferrolle ist ernst geworden
die top figur trump das monster der
tycoon der volksheld wurde zu einem der
mächtigsten männer der welt
jetzt haben wir aber nie wieder
offensichtlich ein paradigmenwechsel bei
denen besagt dass jetzt kein spiel mehr
wir machen ernst diesem gen ist ist es
wir machen ernst den finden sie bei
allen populisten von von trump über über
die presseleute
für alle die dieses wir spielen nicht
mehr mit unserem getränk sein und machen
daraus kein theater oder so etwas kann
keine erscheinung sondern sondern wir
setzen das jetzt um die wirklichkeit um
doch in wirklichkeit ist das phänomen
kommt so schreibt georg seeßlen in
seinem buch nur ein symptom für das
langsame verschwinden einer
demokratischen kultur in der vernunft
fakten und argumente zählten stattdessen
regieren inszenierungen und monströse
gefühle
die letzten sätze in seinem buch lauten
die demokratie ist nicht zu retten
es sei denn man würde die neu erfinden